with respect to the content that comes
from
um like red pills for the creators
whether it's books blogs or videos is
there is there anything or are there
things that you disagree with are the
things that you think they get wrong
that are potentially damaging that they
should revisit
no I think that the main danger is it's
like a half truth it's like a little
knowledge is a dangerous thing a lot of
the red pill guys are there are telling
a version of the truth and they have
facts to back it up but I think the tone
and the goal there is just to Fan the
Flames of male anger so I think it's
really about the intention and the tone
versus the the facts or the content a
lot of that content is
and here's the other thing it's like
you can tell people even really
difficult truths really painful things
if you do it with the right tone
but what I have found and maybe it's
maybe it's a Persona that they're
putting on because I haven't met a lot
of these guys personally I don't know
but there's this almost like over
aggressive machismo to a lot of the red
pill content creators that I think is
kind of an act and I think is people
just especially women they just hear the
tone and they're not willing to listen
anymore and I don't really see the point
of that especially if a lot of red pill
commentators are talking about how women
are this and women are that well yeah
women aren't perfect neither are guys
and if you actually want women to listen
you got to talk in a way that they're
going to be willing to hear otherwise
they're just going to they're just going
to shut down and you're ending up
preaching to your own little Echo
chamber of howling Angry Men
do you think that women listen to this
stuff
I think if you talk to them in the right
way they might I don't think that
they're on your Channel
I think they they used to be used to
start your videos with my brothers and
sisters you haven't done that in a while
yeah I noticed that
um most of my views came from men so I
dropped uh uh brothers and sisters sort
of thing and
um the other thing I noticed too is that
when women watch the content they either
I mean they usually do it from a place
of
um
you know how they say that men peak in
their mid to late 30s on the sexual
Marketplace and women peak in their
early 20s
um I don't generally have 23 year old
women watching my content or calling in
my shows when they do they tend to be
late 30s early 40s maybe even 50s you
know sort of thing and they're trying to
square away their past and
find
maybe maybe there's a part where they're
looking for some answers but they're
also trying to find a connection with a
strong virtuous mailing I think because
they're tired of dealing with soft
weaker men sort of thing and you know I
guess the point of all that is is it
seems like women only want to hear this
message like they'll listen to it but I
don't think they hear it until
they're I mean I hate to use the term
pass or expiry date but until they're
older like until they're they're no
longer in their Prime because I think at
their prime it doesn't matter to them
you know if you're 23 year old and
even if you're average looking you're
still hot
um you know guys will give you lots of
attention all you have to do is have an
Instagram you know with some generous
you know photography with the right
angle and lighting and you two will also
be popular and it's something that men
don't
have the opportunity to benefit from
especially in their 20s like nobody
really pays attention to a 23 year old
guy if he's posting an Instagram shot
but if a gal does it it's you know
there's a lot of attention put on that
so it seems like they don't hear it
until they get older what's your take on
that I think there's some truth to that
just like some guys don't come to it or
really hear it until they've suffered
some sort of rejection or setback maybe
it takes the equivalent of that for
women to be able to open up to the idea
that maybe some of the beliefs under
which they are operating are not
ultimately going to get them what they
want I think that's fair I think men do
the same thing but it comes from a
different angle and you're absolutely
right it's very very difficult to be a
young man like a 20 year old man is
basically useless like men don't want
him because he has no skills or
experience how is he going to benefit
the team women don't want him because
he's got nothing to give them unless
he's you know six foot three and he's
really cute yeah so it's very very
difficult to be a young man people will
step over Over You on the street you're
functionally invisible and you get to
earn your visibility by creating
something of value by becoming a person
of value and that's how you become
visible to your fellow man and that's
how you become visible to women as a
potential sexual
um mate now but what I'm talking about
let me let me talk just a little bit
more here Rich about this idea so I
think it has a lot to do with tone and
how you approach the idea so let's take
the example of hypergamy so you can
approach hypergamy from a couple of
different angles there are guys uh and
some red pill comment
um some red pill content creators they
frame hypergamy as women are just gold
diggers all they care about is a man's
resources and uh they're just out to get
what they can from you and if you have
no money you got no honey there's still
a little truth to that right but you can
also look at it from another angle which
is hey ladies I get it you're just
trying to get the best possible option
that you can have
and like men also want to get the best
possible option that they can have and
the way that women
can conceptualize what is the best
possible option for them also through
the lens of their own biology which has
to do with the fact that you know
they're generally smaller they're weaker
they're especially vulnerable during
childbirth it makes sense that they
would want a devoted man of some
resources to take care of her and her
children so like yeah she wants the best
that she can get don't you dude don't
you want the best that you can get and
it's like oh okay that kind of makes a
little little bit of sense
like I think you can you can talk about
hypergamy in a way that doesn't make
women feel like they're just
materialistic gold diggers and make men
either Furious or hopeless over the
prospect of ever attracting a high
quality woman I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out